hello
um jsconf has actually been a really
amazing experience for me
over the last couple of days i've been
to a lot of tech conferences in my life
and i want to thank
all the organizers and specifically yan
for encouraging me to speak
i've really only spoken in public maybe
once or twice i've given this
talk once at berlin.js to about maybe
15 people so i'm no stranger to the
internet
the javascript community is not i'm not
a javascript coder but i have a lot of
background in the internet
so this talk is a little bit about your
roots so i think in order to
know what you're doing and where you
come from you need to know a little bit
about the history of the industry that
you work in
so i think
technology and
this this talk is basically about
history and culture so history and
culture
is something that drives everything that
we do on a daily basis
how you eat how you look at the world
how you create art
how you create music
and i think sometimes people forget that
your industry also has a history because
sometimes it's work and maybe
you don't think about where it came from
so this whole talk is about the roots of
our industry and how we ended up
becoming
technologists and are able to empower
people to do things and there's
a little bit of i want to guide you
through some of the history
of silicon valley specifically
because it's actually near and dear to
me and i've lived
i've lived there for 11 years so
hi i'm lindsay yank i am currently
an independent product manager and for
the sake of this talk an amateur
historian
you can find me all over the internet at
l inc
i believe in german it's inc
but i have a background in interaction
design
visual communications but i also studied
history
and i'm pretty avidly into politics and
culture as well
less than two weeks ago i moved to
berlin i used jsconf as an excuse to
finally move
um and that's not a joke i've been
coming between berlin and san francisco
for at least yearly since 2009 i first
visited berlin in 1998
so this city and its culture and its
history is really important to me when i
studied
visual communications i was also
studying german history as well
this photo is actually from toeflsberg
which is an old caa spy station out in
the west if you've never been there you
should definitely go
but i thought it was ironic that i'm up
there and someone had
graffitied this sf2 berlin graffiti um
i think the two cities actually have a
lot in common and
i kind of want to go i'll get to that at
some point
so i'm not going to talk about myself
for very long but i spent most of my
professional history at apple
i spent 2005 to 2011 working on the
itunes store and app store
i started as an individual ui engineer
doing kind of front-end web development
for
what was not exactly the internet before
2009 itunes finally switched over to
webkit
i think in november of 2009 we kind of
got up to speed with how the internet
was working so i'm no stranger to
internet technology
and what it can do and how it affects
people
my team basically created all like
interactive web prototypes
promotions if you see anything for
itunes london right now which is
happening
we worked on all the backend systems and
the front end systems to make
to make that technology work but i quit
three years ago
because i needed a break and i needed to
do something different
i actually spent three months in berlin
when i left
so i think this leads up nicely into a
quote
that i think we're possibly
all familiar with and stay hungry stay
foolish
has been i think misappropriated to
steve jobs a lot because he mentioned it
in a 2005 stanford speech
and especially after he died
people started making you know making
the steve's quote and in fact it
actually
came from the back of something called
the whole earth catalog
so i'm going to go through a little bit
of the history of it but the 1960s
hippie
california counterculture really
influenced how we got to personal
computing
and technology today so i'm going to
introduce stuart brandt
stuart brand is the brainchild of the
whole earth catalog
he is a stanford educated biologist with
an interest in politics and art as well
he also worked on the mother of all
demos which you guys might know with
doug engelbart and it was a famous
presentation of
a lot of revolutionary computer
technologies including hypertext email
and the mouse when stuart brand
was a kid he was running around on this
hippie bus with a band of people called
the mary pranksters
uh the merry pranksters were really
trying to
get this is in 1964 by the way um the
mary pranksters were really trying to
um they were literally dropping lsd into
middle america by driving this bus
around and throwing spontaneous parties
and doing drugs and
getting cold war america to basically
see an alternative to a more adventurous
and harmonious way to live so the mary
pranksters were not actually afraid of
technology there was a big sentiment of
people really rejecting technology at
the time because it was mostly being
used for war
um so the mary praying for pranksters
really
deployed technology to create new
consciousness and
a new form of social organization i
could talk
for days about counterculture but if you
would like to read a little bit more
about that
bit of the counterculture there's a book
called the electrocooled acid test if
you've read it
you know but otherwise it's a good
reference for
where this mindset was coming from but i
also want to talk about what was going
on in silicon valley at the time
silicon valley actually has a large root
in military technology
and military investment basically so
stanford actually created a
link between the department of defense
and technology so military satellites
were being being developed in silicon
valley
previously back to the 1920s through the
40s and 50s
they were making vacuum tubes microwave
missiles and satellites at some point
silicon valley became known for what it
is because of the microprocessor
so there was this anti-technology
sentiment going on at the time this is a
student protesting at stanford about
he's got a punch card around his neck
that says strike and so there was
a there was a very large part of people
who were really not into technology at
the time
so the counterculture that you're
probably used to seeing
is more of these protesters out with
signs
and out in front of berkeley and trying
to change things
based on standing around with science
but there was a bit of a division
between the counter cultures so there
was this new left idea
and i'm before i go through this slide i
want to actually credit um
fred turner who wrote this book from
counterculture to cyber culture with
this because he kind of divided these
two
countercultures but the new left was
really working through
bureaucracy and hierarchy
organization and established structures
the new
communalists which would you would
consider stewart brands and these kids
dropping acid
but they were also quite smart they were
using small scale technologies
lsd lots of buckminster fuller
inspiration
diy technology and shared mindset and
community building
the difference is is that the new left
was trying to work with
the established systems and these new
communalists were really just like you
know what
this is up we don't have anything
to do with you we're going to do
something totally different
there's a story of a protest at berkeley
where
ken kesey is looking at these kids
protesting saying
what are you going to do stand there
with trans signs and change something
and he just starts to play his harmonica
so this was kind of the mindset of the
people that were going on there
um so
if the american state deployed massive
weapons to destroy faraway people
this new idea was that we would deploy
deploy small-scale technologies to bring
people together
the counterculture looked a little bit
like this this is one of the first
communes that existed it's called drop
city and it was in
colorado so people started
moving away from their homes to create
this new
this new city this new idea and this new
way of living
that was actually around a common
humanity um
literally dome was the new home this is
it was it was literally like okay cool
like your suburban houses are square
and we're gonna go live in domes uh
because seriously this whole system is
up and we're about ready to get
you know bombed by someone um
but there was also this notion
of uh distribu like distributed working
so this slide says
if you can read it says workers of the
world disperse which i don't think is so
uncommon to how you and i can work today
because we have laptops and we can
you we can do our craft independently so
i think that there's kind of a link
between this and how we can work today
san francisco basically became the heart
of
a new world for the united states and so
people were coming from all over the
country to experience what this new
world was like
and again this is not so different to
how i see people trying to flock to
san francisco today but it really was
the heart of it and it was a very it was
very much centered in the west coast
but to introduce the catalogues to our
brands
on an acid trip sitting on a hill in san
francisco literally was looking out at
the earth and he saw the horizon of the
earth bending
and he wondered why haven't we actually
seen
a photo of the whole earth yet this was
in 1966.
so he started a public campaign for nasa
to um publish a photo of the whole earth
because he believed that it was a
powerful symbol for humanity especially
when you're basically facing nuclear war
um it evoked a shared sense of destiny
and adaptive strategies for people and
so the whole earth catalog was born and
this is the front of the catalog
it basically became a manual for people
who were living on the land
but the difference was is that the
catalog
didn't sell anything it was only a
portal so when steve jobs
mentioned this in his stanford speech he
was talking about
how this was kind of like google before
google existed 35 years before
it didn't sell anything but the purpose
of the catalog
was basically to
empower people to do their own thing so
this says
we're as gods we might as well get used
to it um
in response to i can actually carry this
but um this was the purpose of the
catalog the calendar was also user
contributed
content so people would write in uh
things that they thought were useful
and would say hey i i think that you
should really publish this in your
catalog and it didn't matter who you
were and
they would just go ahead and publish it
but i'm actually going to pull up i'm
going to keep this quote up here so you
can actually read it
because i think this is the core of
the thinking at the time and the
thinking around this catalog
and this movement highly influenced
everyone that created personal
technology today
so this is the inside of the catalog
like i said readers could submit
information
and it also it included a lot of books
and it was a lot of
books around mindset and thinking not
around necessarily how to make gardens
so it was it was not only a functional
tool
for you know how to build your dome
but also a consciousness tool on how to
really think about the world
here's another one i actually brought my
copy of the whole earth catalog with me
to berlin because it's one of most my
most kind of prized
objects i have it if you guys want to
see it afterward
i haven't actually even taken it out of
its wrappings from when i flew with it
because it's really fragile
this stuff was printed on really really
cheap newsprint paper um
and one of the things that i think is
interesting is that at some point this
calculator showed up
and it was a four thousand nine hundred
dollar calculator that was listed in the
catalog
nothing was too it had to be good and
had to be
uncommon knowledge to be in the catalog
so the founding editor of wired magazine
actually was an editor of the whole
earth catalog
and he basically said look strip brand
created the blogosphere before there was
even an internet
so the idea of the whole earth was
basically that
people could rally around and
get together around their common ideas
which is again
really not so different than what we do
on the internet today on twitter
and wherever so
this is a photo of alan kaye uh and
the first gui and xerox park library
actually had a lot of the books from the
catalog in their library so allen k
actually talks about how he was really
influenced by
the thinking of that of that time
um and this counterculture
started to actually permeate into
university labs
and um at
the stanford uh ai institute there was
this
there's a story about how people um
would sit around naked in a sauna
smoking pot waiting for the code to
compile
because you had to schedule your time
and so what do you do you smoke some
weed and you
compile your code at some point so
there's there's a lot of this history
and it goes on forever it
it really goes on forever and i'm
fascinated by it
but the whole earth wasn't just the
catalog there was this whole network of
people
and ideas that started to come around so
there were publications
after the whole earth whole earth was
from 1968 to 74.
um next slide is that there was also
this thing called the well which i'll
get into
fairly in a second there's also this
global business network that brands are
part of which actually is owned by
deloitte that
enables government agencies and
businesses to think about long-term
thinking
rather than really short-term thinking
wired magazine which i'm sure you all
know
and the long now foundation which is
what stuart brand is currently involved
in in san francisco
this is a photo of the well the well is
still active on the internet today
uh it's the oldest continuously running
online community since 1985. it was
started as a bbs
so it's been on the internet since
30 years 30 years is a long time
especially in internet time
it's mostly known for its internet
forums it also provided email
shell accounts access to create web
pages
it became one of the original isps
actually when the
when commercial traffic was finally
allowed on the internet
and what else is interesting about this
is that the founders of the electronic
frontier foundation
actually met on the well and so they
started talking about this idea
and it was it was kind of this whole
earth turns into the internet
we continue talking about our ideas and
moving forward
so terms that kind of came out of these
are things that you know
personal computer virtual community
electronic frontier
so these people are all connected and
they're all part of
um part of our history and part of why
we can all sit in this room today
because
we're from i'm from the united states
there are people from all over the world
here
there's a lot this is required reading i
think if you work in technology
so from counter culture to cyber culture
is written by fred turner
i've met him he's become a friend of
mine this is an academic approach
to how the counterculture really
influenced silicon valley and california
a nice story about fred is that he
actually uh
lived in kreuzberg in the early 80s he
worked at a punk theater
and was also part of the counter culture
here in berlin
which i thought was really interesting
but he's a professor at samford now and
this is a really great book
and a great take it's a bit it's a
longer but
if you would like a more journalistic
approach there's this other book called
what the dormouse said
um by mark hoffman there are some of
these anecdotes about how
the east coast and versus west coast
ideology
was shaping how personal computing and
thinking about computing actually happen
so i don't know if you guys are
really clued into what's going on in san
francisco right now
but i don't know what the happened
i've lived there for 11 years and
we have a war criminal on the board of
dropbox
we have obama's
campaign advisor advising uber on how to
do public policy
so we've gone from rejecting to man to
totally becoming the man
we've gone from rejecting military and
all of these things to
becoming a part of it and i've been in
san francisco this stuff
this has been in the blogs forever and
it's been coming up for years and years
but
now it's it's in the international
press it's all over the place
here's another one from the economist so
this notion of
i don't know this notion of this
idealized society has turned into
a basically really hyper-capitalistic
view of how everything should work um
and here's one from a german newspaper
and i'm not really sure what happened
um here are some ideas about possibly
what happened
the counterculture in california was
pretty homogeneous so most of people
were our middle class
white they excluded outsiders it was
really clicky
and there were traditional gender roles
on commune so there are photos of women
you know carrying loaves of bread while
the men's work in fields
um charisma was a really huge part of
how you became a leader on the commune
um and
it was kind of you know cool and you can
kind of see this reflected in
cultures at say like google or even
apple and it's it's a little bit
disturbing because there's a story of
you know somebody mentioned it's like oh
yeah you work at google it's really
great but then like the guy behind the
counter serving you free lunch
is making less than minimum wage and
you're kind of in this weird bubble
about how you think you're changing the
world but you're really
just kind of causing this disparity to
continue
um so
we need to re-identify i really believe
in this and
what i see happening especially within
the u.s and around the world is people
want to copy silicon valley
and i don't think you can do it it's it
was centered in
history and culture and a place in time
and it's you've got silicon valley in
california
great makes sense we made some silicon
ships but you've got silicon
ali here in berlin you've also got
silicon katie apparently which somebody
just told me about
um you have silicon roundabout in london
which i'll get to which i think is funny
there's silicon forest in portland
there's silicon beach in la
and you have this rubber stamp of people
copying a culture
that doesn't make sense so first of all
can we stop calling things silicon do
you guys know anybody who makes silicon
chips
really do you does anyone in the room
one okay
apps javascript not silicon chips
so i think it's time that we re-identify
and relook and also this culture is
really old
you know this culture is like i actually
feel like we're kind of at the same
we're at a same historical moment with
everything that's going on in the world
with
nsa we've got wars going on all over the
place and i think it's really time that
we
re-look and re-identify what we're doing
um
but is anyone from london in the room
silicon roundabout silken roundabout was
a joke that came up in a pub
by my friend matt biddoff but had been
co-opted and written about
and then i think the government got
involved started like funding the
funding the roundabout funding these
things it was a joke
it's crazy so
my point is is that we all come from
totally different
like historical and cultural backgrounds
and it's really important
especially in a place like europe and
berlin like
we come from totally different mindsets
so trying to rubber stamp silicon valley
doesn't make sense
so you should be london
you should be dublin you should be paris
you should be amsterdam and please
stay berlin
i mean it i see the same kind of things
going on here in the city and i chose to
move here because it reminded me of san
francisco
11 years ago and i think
this room really gives me a lot of
optimism because everyone i've met
over the weekend is super awesome super
interesting
really about
i don't know being creative and using
technology for creative means and so
it's it's frustrating to watch it happen
but if i
have a say while i'm still here i will
make sure that berlin stays berlin
and you guys do what you need to do
because
we started out about we needed to lower
thresholds and empower individuals and i
don't
i think we need to get back to that and
as you move on this is the back of the
last full earth catalog
stay hungry stay foolish and thank you
for letting me talk
you